on a presque tous déjà crû à des forces
nouvelles et le coupable c'est notre
cerveau à travers l'évolution notre
cerveau à développer des biais cognitif
c'est en quelque sorte des raccourcis
psychologique qui ont aidé nos ancêtres
à prendre des décisions et à survivre
dans la nature mais sur internet c'est
même biais cognitifs nous rendre
vulnérable aux fausses nouvelles et même
aux théories du complot je m'appelle
bouchra wathiq et voici cinq raisons
pour lesquelles on croit les fausses
nouvelles premièrement on aime avoir
raison on a tendance à chercher
l'information qui confirme ce qu'on
pense déjà et à rejeter une information
qui nous contredit pour nos ancêtres le
biais de confirmation les aider à
filtrer l'information et à pouvoir
réagir plus rapidement mais sur internet
ça fait qu'on risque de croire des
fausses nouvelles parts ce qui nous
conforte dans nos opinions
notre mémoire nous trompe on a tendance
à penser que ce qui est familier est
vrai et ça peut lui jouer des tours
par exemple si on vous montre une fausse
nouvelle et qu'on vous dit que les
fausses si vous la voyez quelques jours
plus tard vous allez peut-être penser
que les vrais juste parce que vous
l'aurez déjà vu on se méfie des dangers
et on voit parfois des dangers l'oignon
l'alcool pour nos enceintes c'est normal
que si quelqu'un les prévenait des
dangers il allait le prendre au sérieux
et ne pas prendre de risque mais sur
internet beaucoup de fausses nouvelles
nous avertissent de danger qui n'existe
pas vraiment par exemple tous les
articles qui exagèrent les risques
associés aux vaccins
on cherche un sens aux événements qu'un
événement grave se produit on cherche
une cause ou un responsable et c'est
normal de réagir ainsi parce que si on
connaît la cause
on sera capable de mieux réagir à
l'avenir tandis que si on pense que
l'événement est accidentelle on se
sentira un puissant mais parfois notre
cerveau imagine des causes qui ne sont
pas réels par exemple l'incendié récent
à la cathédrale notre dame de paris est
accidentelle mais certaines personnes on
imaginer qu'il y avait un complot
finalement on a besoin de faire partie
d'un groupe depuis la préhistoire les
humains s'organise en clans et est
souvent des rivalités entre les groupes
donc on a tendance à croire
l'information qui favorise notre groupe
est celle qui dénigrent les autres
courent c'est une façon pour lui mais
d'affirmer son sentiment d'appartenance
mais souvent les forces nouvelles joue
sur ces rivalités comme on le voit très
souvent en période d'élection une fois
qu'on est conscient de ces biais
cognitifs qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire on
pourra jamais s'en débarrasser parce que
notre cerveau a évolué de cette façon là
mais quand on voit une nouvelle qui nous
fait réagir on peut prendre le temps de
se demander si on n'est pas en train
d'être victime de biais cognitif
on peut aussi discuter avec des gens qui
ont des opinions contraires à la nôtre
parce qu'un débat tant on peut
confronter ses opinions et se rendre
compte si elles sont vraies ou fausses
c'est bien nous rappelle aussi qu'on n'a
pas toujours raison et que comme
n'importe qui on peut se tromper
avez vous des solutions pour contrer vos
biens cognitifs
si oui dites nous dans les commentaires